a nantes une marche blanche tout à
l'heure en mémoire de steve deux ans
après la mort du jeune homme tombé dans
la loire pendant l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre à la fin de la fête de
la musique en 2019
une marche suivie d'un autre
rassemblement place du bouffay où l'on
retrouve en direct nadège abderrazak
bonsoir neiges comment se passe ce
rassemblement en hommage à steve on
rappelle que la première marche était
autorisé la deuxième ne l'est pas alors
stéphanie on se trouve sur les quais de
la loire toujours là où ce type maya
canesso et bien a perdu la vie il ya
deux ans jour pour jour alors on est en
compagnie des proches de steve maya
canesso quelques membres de sa famille
des amis du membre du collectif justice
pour steve alors c'est une marche qui
s'est déroulée assez dans le calme dans
une ambiance assez solennel également
extrêmement entendu vous vous en doutez
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'émotion lors de
cette marche une marche qui a commencé
depuis la préfecture de police de loire
atlantique et qui est bien c'est terminé
ici même donc sur les clo quai au niveau
du quai wilson là où donc steve maya
canesso a perdu la vie il y a deux ans
alors l'objectif de ce millier de
personnes plus d'un millier de personnes
a participé à ce rendez vous à cet
hommage
aujourd'hui c'était justement de se
rappeler de rendre hommage à steve
mailhac à nice au ils ont aussi demandé
justice ils ont appelé le parquet de
rennes à continuer ses investigations
pour qu'ils puissent aboutir à des vrais
des vraies qualifications il souhaite
que la mort de steve maya canesso et
bien soit requalifiée en homicide
involontaire ils cherchent des
responsabilités donc plusieurs personnes
vont prochainement être interrogé par
les enquêteurs le maire de nantes et son
adjoint à la sécurité de l'époque ainsi
que le préfet de loire atlantique et le
sous préfet le directeur départemental
chargé de la sécurité publique également
alors on va rejoindre un sens plus tard
des carreaux qui est membre du collectif
justice pour steve bonjour merci de nous
accorder à ces quelques minutes alors
l'émotion était vraiment très intense
aujourd'hui pour cette marche blanche
c'était important de rendre hommage à
steve mailhac à nice aux deux ans jour
pour jour après sa disparition
forcément que ça reste important ça
l'est pour tout être qui meurent de base
mais du coup pour un être qui meurt et
auquel il n'y a pas de vérité derrière
qu'il n'ya pas non plus de finalité qui
n'est encore moins de points c'est
encore plus important ça nous permet
aussi de retrouver une force de
retrouver un équilibre entre vérité et
surtout également aussi un moment de
d'une pression pour obtenir une vérité
on veut pas forcément de répercussions
dramatiques où on n'est pas là pour
déclarer une guerre ou ou pour être des
rebelles incontesté ou autre on est
simplement des réponses une vérité pour
simplement trouver la paix quelle
réponse vous recherchez aujourd'hui à
les réponses fin c'est surtout des
réponses sur des démentis qu'est lieu
des mensonges des manipulations des
cachotteries tout ce qui était lieu que
pour nous s'est déclarée comme une
injustice comme du coup un manque de
pouvoir être rampait d'être calme
notamment pour la famille qui a été le
plus dur c'est pour ça que nous les amis
on a décidé de créer un collectif afin
de ne pas prendre les devants auprès de
tous même pour voir être une force pour
nous être un peu comme une béquille pour
les soutenir d'avancer et de leur
montrer que du coup ils ne sont pas
seuls ils ont droit de pleurer qu'ils
ont voit ne pas être bien et que quoi
qu'il arrive même s'il tombe à des
moments où on sera toujours là et pour
les relever et pour faire avancer les
choses
quand vous parlez de mensonges de
cachotteries vous pensez à qui aux
policiers à l'igpn qui a conclu par
exemple et bien à un accident de la mort
de steve majaka nisoli gpn à aa dit
s'est fermement et rapidement que steve
mailhac nguesso était tombé
accidentellement absolument pas alors de
cette charge policière alors c'est
quelque chose qui il y a trois jours a
été contredit par le parquet de rennes
qui lui affirme après investigations que
steve maniaque à nice au est bien tombé
dans la loire
après cette charge policière vous pensé
à ça quand vous dites cachotteries
mensonge à ses conclusions de de l'igpn
ça en fait partie également mais ce
n'est pas que il ya eu un des nombreux
de mensonges depuis le début et eu un
mensonge pour la personnalité déjà un
des intégrales de steve ce n'était soi
qu'un drogué soit qu'un chauffeur qu'il
était dans un rassemblement de free
party alors que parle du tout nous
étions bel et bien à la fête de la
musique une chose qui deux ans après est
encore dans l'oubli pourtant on est
toujours là à parler de fête techno de
rave party des free parties alors que
pas du tout nous fêtions comme
l'intégralité de cette planète terre en
ce moment là parce que c'est quand même
une fête internationale le 21 juin avec
toute légalité comme depuis 2008 où on
est en place et que tout est légal parce
que du coup la fête de la musique c'est
une représentation comme commémorative à
toutes les cultures musicales veut dire
que toutes les cultures musicales en
droit d'exprimer leur musique on reste à
recracher du son c'est une
journée dans l'année où tout le monde
fait la fête et du coup nous là on est
voulu la première chose de démentis
c'est que nous on n'était pas dans un
rassemblement illégal contraire c'était
bien protégés deuxième mensonge était
également de la personnalité de steve
également de qu'il était facile de
catégoriser quelqu'un que comme c'est un
rêveur un teufeur bas c'est forcément un
drogué un irresponsable ce qui n'est pas
du tout le cas de cette personne bien au
contraire en plus pareil démentir sur le
fait de son responsabilités alors qu'il
ne faisait rien d'autre que d'être
présents de danser et en plus au moment
des faits est également en train d'aider
des dj a et 1,2 sont donc à ranger le
matériel donc à faire ce que la police
avait demandé finalement et qu'au lieu
de sava voilà il s'est retrouvé on ne
dit pas que là ce n'est pas un accident
à l'état pur c'est sa commune d'une
erreur certes ce qui a entraîné un
accident
du coup cette charge policière ça c'est
vous étiez sur place vous à 7
à ce moment là on sait que les policiers
présents ont lancé plusieurs grenades de
gaz lacrymogène c'est d un acte qui a
poussé à la loire en quinze personnes
dont steve vous dites que les policiers
ont mal agi à ce moment là que c'était
irresponsable d'utiliser ce matériel de
maintien de l'ordre
à ce moment là à tout près de la loi
tout à fait déjà on va repartir sur la
base que du coup nous a fait longtemps
qu'on vient ici longtemps que du coup on
a des autorisations très bien d'habitude
on commence de la grue jaune et ça c'est
ans là-bas pour justement permettre aux
gens détendre au maximum et vite et j'ai
trop assemblement parce que du coup même
nous on trouvait ça un peu dangereux
fait des années qu'on réclame le départ
hier pour nous protéger des années que
la mairie ne nous met rien en place pour
nous protéger qu'on a obligé d'avoir mes
propres moyens ce qui n'est pas
forcément facile pour des gens civils de
toutes parts donc oui il ya eu ça il ya
eu également le fait qu'effectivement
d'un coup charge et sans réelle
sommation et d'un coup balancer un
nombre incalculable de la fimo gène
lacrymogènes ça a un effet de brouillard
beaucoup plus qu épée ou du coup on ne
peut pas respirer on ne peut pas ouvrir
les yeux on pleure on est traumatisé
savoir que du coup les grenades d
encerclement ça envoie des éclairs un
petit peu également du coup les gens
sont complètement désorienté forcément
faire ça à trois mètres de la loire il
suffit pas même un enfant de 5 ans c'est
vrai que ce serait dangereux du coup
pour moi il n'y a aucune raison et
une excuse pour dire qu'on avait pas vu
où c'était dangereux vous êtes
satisfaite de l'organisation de cette
marche blanche aujourd'hui ça s'est
passé dans le calme jusqu'à la fin de
cette marche blanche ici à leur petit
couac peut-être lorsque les forces de
l'ordre ont refusé d'abord l'accès à la
famille au quai wilson
ils ont autorisé quelques yeux quelques
minutes plus tard mais comment qu'elle
est dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
vous êtes satisfait de cette marche vous
je suis d'un côté parce qu'on a quand
même pu réussir a quand même mal et
quand même quelque part on a quand même
pu être là on a quand même dû faire un
minimum de rage il ya une partie de moi
qui l'ait et une autre partie qu'il
n'est pas du tout parce que du coup je
rappelle toujours que ça fait deux ans
qu'on fait des événements ça fait deux
ans qu'on est en charge de beaucoup de
choses qu'on est en place énormément de
choses qu'on rassemble énormément de
monde que jusque là on a toujours réussi
à faire reculer la police et qu'il soit
le moins possible parce que nous on a
toujours été en charge de la sécurité
il n'y a jamais eu de débordement jamais
de cassage et qu'aujourd'hui voir que du
coup ils arrivent et qui nous en empêche
totalement en du clan craignant que d'un
coup du jour au lendemain en deviennent
des personnes qu'on ait des personnes
violentes ou irresponsable oui ça fait
tomber des nues totalement parce que du
coup encore une fois on a l'impression
que du coup ils nous écoutent jamais ils
ne regardent pas et à aucun moment il
réfléchit sur qui on est ce qu'on fait
et du coup interdire une famille même
interdire des amis aller un lieu public
ou en plus même si certains y avait rien
à cacher rien à faire dans un lieu
presque abandonné loin de tout loin de
traite chose juste une fresque est un
endroit qui est commémorative et du coup
pour moi encore une fois il n'y a aucune
raison valable de nous avoir interdit c1
reste encore une fois une injustice de
plus à rajouter dossier qu'est ce que
vous allez faire maintenant peut-être
surveiller de près les investigations
attendre que peut-être justice soit
faite pour steve vous attendez quoi
particulièrement
alors nous on attend bas on se bat pour
que justement les vérités sortent parce
que oui c'est vrai le rapport de l'igpn
était totalement démenti non pas parce
que d'un coup la justice a décidé de
faire son travail ou fait son travail
mais parce qu'on l'a poussé à faire son
travail parce qu'on a toujours été là
parce qu'on a mobilisé du monde parce
qu'on a mobilisé le public
on a beaucoup entendu des vous pleurez
sur les réseaux alors qu'il ya une
différence entre des lancers et pleurer
ces deux choses totalement différentes
et aujourd'hui on est dans un esprit tu
as
combative mais pas combatif guerrier
combative simplement on s'en fout on est
là on a envie on a nos émotions on a des
choses
et la vérité c'est un combat juste et du
coup on n'est pas là pour faire quelque
chose d'injuste ou ramener du manque de
respect ni envers eux ni envers personne
juste on se respecte nous on respecte la
famille on respecte notre défunt et on
respecte simplement la vie et le cycle
de la vie c'est du coup d'avancé et
quand il ya une chose qui se passe on en
discute ya un dialogue qui se fait et
tant que la vérité se met en place
toujours plus facile d'avancer vers la
paix et vers des choses celle merci
beaucoup un carrosse rappellent que vous
êtes membre du collectif justice pour ce
qui va vous l'avez entendu ans stéphanie
cette militante qui bien attend
patiemment que justice soit faite pour
pour steve alors allez satisfaite de
l'organisation de cette marche même si
elle estime qu'il ya eu quelques couacs
1 notamment lors de l'accès au quai
wilson pour les membres de la famille
ici présent voilà ce que l'on peut dire
sur cette journée de commémoration
aujourd'hui en hommage de la stib maya
canesso qui a donc disparu
il y a deux ans jour pour jour ici même
sur ce quai wilson et qui a été retrouvé
un mois plus tard mort noyé dans les
eaux merci nadège à dera sach en direct
de nantes